We know that gender inequality is still a major issue in our society.
But we also know that we have the power to change.
That we can all be a part of this movement
by supporting and uplifting each other.
We can break down barriers and achieve great things.
We are all unique. We are all unique quality.
And we will be free. Equality
and we will be free. Be the change.
Embrace the change. Be the change.
Embrace the change. Together,
let's create a world of acceptance and love.
Be yourself.
Empower each other. Empower ourselves.
Different is not wrong. It's just different.
Everyone deserve respect. Everyone deserve respect.
Everyone deserves respect.
Together, we can make a difference.
Together we can break down barriers and achieve greatness.
Let's rise up and empower each other to create a better world for all.